a 38 year old citizen journalist in a
chinese prison is close to death and all
calls for china to release her have so
far gone unheeded
zhang jian was sentenced to four years
in prison last year for court picking
quarrels and provoking trouble her crime
reporting from wuhan as a citizen
journalist in february twenty twenty her
reports filmed on her smartphone painted
a picture of chaos and disorganization
in the then epicenter of the coronavares
outbreak
a picture that went counter to official
chinese government narratives
her family now says she is on hunger
strike and could be on the brink of
death it's prompted no less than the u.n
the european union the united states and
germany to call on the chinese
government to release her
pressure is also mounting from rights
organizations and journalists
this from the german branch of amnesty
international jang jan who reported on
kovid when it first appeared in china is
at grave risk of dying she has to be
released immediately
and this from denis yugel an
award-winning german journalist who was
jailed by turkey on concocted espionage
charges zhang could have saved the world
if she'd been able to carry on her work
at the start of the coronavirus pandemic
the world has a duty to help her
including the german government
in a moment i'll be speaking to the
germany head of reporters without
borders on what form that help could
take but first here's more on jung jan
and her work in wuhan
this was the scene a year ago chinese
authorities pushing back against
unwanted attention a journalist was
being sentenced four years behind bars
for zhengjun the charges picking
quarrels and provoking trouble john's
been in custody since may 2020. she's
gone on several hunger strikes her
lawyers say she's been force-fed
what i'm most worried about is that
she's such a determined person
still thinks she's innocent and we both
pleaded her innocence in court
and the court gave such a harsh sentence
she is probably more determined to
continue her hunger strike until the
very end
so i'm very worried about her health and
her life
[Music]
during the lockdown in wuhan zhangjun
put up critical posts on twitter and
youtube that were blocked by chinese
authorities her reports dealt with
everyday problems in hospitals and
official corruption jiang john is one of
several citizen journalists who ran
afoul of the authorities in wuhan
there are many similar cases of human
rights abuses in china you never hear
from these people again some are allowed
to go home others disappear zhang jian
is the only one so far to actually end
up in court
the united states says it's keeping an
eye on china's mistreatment of jung
next the united states is deeply
concerned about the deteriorating health
of prc citizen journalist miss zhang
jhan according to multiple reports
citing her relatives comments ms zhang
is near death
we reiterate our call to the prc for her
immediate and unconditional release
china continues to deal harshly with
criticism of its handling of the
pandemic it appears determined to stop
people like zhang jian from questioning
the official message that its response
was anything but swift and effective
and reporters without borders is one of
the organizations calling for zhang's
release earlier in the month it awarded
zhang with its 2021 press freedom award
in the courage category i'm joined now
by executive director of reporters
without borders germany christian meer
christian welcome how concerned are you
that zhang could actually die in prison
we are very concerned as reporters about
borders because zhang jian is on hangar
strike protesting against the arbitrary
detention
and
we actually try to raise our voice try
to alert the public that actually
she's facing actually possible deaths
because she's arbitrarily detained is
she's protesting against it
uh you've raised your voice and you've
also asked for germany to act and to try
and secure the release of zhang do you
think germany is doing enough
i mean one could always ask for more and
i think germany has to be outspoken
because there's always a discussion in
diplomacy whether it should be outspoken
or not but we know that china reacts to
to to countries when they are outspoken
and i mean we now have soon a new
government in germany and i'm really
hoping that this new government will be
definitely strongly outspoken
asking publicly the release of zhang
zhan because this is very much needed
because china reacts to public pressure
but does it really react to pressure i
mean i'm thinking of nobel prize
laureate liu xiaobo for example there
were calls for his release but he wasn't
released he died in 2017 while still
serving his prison sentence in a in a
hospital
there's a challenge actually for states
to act in a coordinated manner and
germany is a eu country and if the eu as
one single voice pushed by germany would
coordinate such a reaction this could
make definitely a difference and for
example we soon will have an olympics
the beijing olympics in february and
china is very much care
cares very much about if it's public
image before and during this olympics
and so this is a window of opportunity
for germany to make pressure and for
china to release her
in terms of the perception and the
messaging within china what is the
message zhang's treatment and
incarceration sends out to concerned
citizens within china
china of course tries to frame her
as
as someone who who created a breast of
someone who who created disinformation
but in fact
that's just pure propaganda because
zhang jian she distributed independent
information on what happened in wuhan
actually the city of the outbreak of the
global pandemic of of covet and so i
think we have to be grateful and we
cannot accept that actually china
gets through with this declaration of
her
creating um
yeah um
that she's actually creating violence
and she's actually creating disturbance
and sis we should china can should not
get through with it
christian we leave it there for the time
being but thank you so much for joining
us today
thank you